[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteras el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la reacción de
france 24 soy herminia fernández
seguimos con nuestra serie de reporteros
dedicada a las fronteras del mundo hoy
con el segundo reportaje los llevaremos
al paso fronterizo entre brasil y la
guyana francesa en sudamérica cerca de
3000 canoas cruzan cada día el río hoy a
poco que divide los dos territorios las
orillas de este río son el escenario de
todo tipo de tráfico inmigración ilegal
y búsqueda clandestina de oro la policía
intenta vigilar todos los movimientos
que ocurren pero es un espacio casi
imposible de controlar la pandemia de
kobe 19 que habría supuesto un cierre
hermético de la frontera no ha hecho
sino demostrar aún más claramente su
gran porosidad a continuación veremos el
informe de fannie lo tea y laura damas
con severin bardón y olivier martín
[Música]
una actividad inusual agita las aguas
del hoy a poco
está cruzando al otro lado agárrense
en el corazón de la selva amazónica el
río representa una parte de los 700
kilómetros de frontera entre la uat era
francesa y brasil llame en un vehículo
de apoyo terrestre aquí no vamos a
desembarcar
cada día unas 3000 piraguas transitan
entre las dos orillas para luchar contra
los cruces clandestinos y los tráficos
que asolan la región
francia y brasil en salida en una
operación fluvial conjunta
buenos días buenos días señor soy
perfecto como están bien
buenos días buenos días
como valoración bonus brasil movilizó
más de 20 hombres todos muy armados en
el lado francés sólo tres embarcaciones
participaron en la operación
frederic wood el el subprefecto de la
guayana francesa que acudió como
observador hacia un balance realista de
la situación
y
se nota el aspecto extremadamente
disuasivo del ejército brasileño eso es
fundamental para esta frontera nosotros
no podemos ocuparnos solos de esta zona
[Música]
actualmente el río separa los
territorios de la guayana francesa de
brasil pero durante mucho tiempo fue el
puente entre las poblaciones indígenas
que habitan en cada una de sus orillas
el odio es el adjunto del jefe tribal de
esperanzados una aldea guayanesa donde
viven unas 60 familias de la etnia
película
sobrina qué tal
abuela cómo estás
en esta remota región francesa de
ultramar más de la mitad de la población
vive por debajo del umbral de la pobreza
como la mayoría de sus vecinos la madre
de orly perdió su trabajo por la
pandemia durante varios meses vivió de
la ayuda alimentaria conseguida por el
estado francés nuestros reservas se
acabaron
sólo nos queda harina todo el resto se
acabó
el detergente también hay que comprar
más
[Música]
y
un pequeño paquete de detergente así
cuesta cinco euros es muy caro
me duele ver que mi madre no puede
comprar lo que necesita para mantener a
nuestra familia
de la familia
ante esa precariedad en aumento las
familias como la de hoy se las arreglan
para sobrevivir
que hay que comprar pollo
del lado brasileño los productos básicos
son 5 veces más baratos que en la
guayana para conseguir unos paquetes de
arroz café y azúcar orly y su madre se
arriesgarán a cruzar la frontera cerrada
por el comido
las poblaciones indígenas en busca de
una vida mejor no son las únicas que
aprovechan la porosidad de la frontera a
50 kilómetros del río arriba la región
de camps y unos gendarmes franceses
tratan de detener la extracción de oro
clandestina la mayoría de los buscadores
vienen del brasil vecino
lo más lejos que hemos sido fue a cuatro
horas y media en piragua de canopy había
rastros por todas partes árboles talados
en medio de los arroyos para que no
pudiéramos pasar
14 gendarme tratan de luchar contra
estas operaciones ilegales en los
alrededores de camping
los patrullajes están llenos de
obstáculos
y se hacen a través de una naturaleza
densa propicia para las actividades
clandestinas
en tierra firme el equipo descubre
rastros recientes de buscadores de oro
todo indica que acaban de irse
después de unos minutos de búsqueda
encuentran a un buscador no tienes
documentos la tarjeta de identidad
tienes documentos
los llevaremos al otro lado le vamos a
decir que no puede volver aquí pero no
le va a importar regresará de inmediato
es un ciclo sin fin de lo sabemos pero
no importa en general no son peligrosos
son personas que están trabajando la
extracción ilegal de oro existe hace más
de 20 años está muy organizada el nombre
que acaban de encontrar estaba encargado
de abastecer a su equipo
esto es lo que yo llamo una mochila
quechua aquí están las correas para los
hombros y esto se lo ponen en la frente
lo llevan aquí para las cargas pesadas
aquí están todos los víveres que habrá
que destruir al regresar
cuando viene alguien de la gente armería
de las farc o cualquier otro ellos
advierten al resto de los
transportadores
y los demás deben estar cerca
seguramente alertados por los vigías los
otros buscadores alcanzaron a huir los
gendarmes dieron al brasileño de vuelta
a su territorio sin ninguna sanción por
falta de medios
la frontera en canopy es enorme tenemos
un poco menos de 15.000 km cuadrados de
circunscripción es gigante
se estima que hay cerca de 10.000
buscadores de oro activos en el
territorio guayanés en los dos últimos
años sólo 99 han sido condenados por la
justicia francesa una gota de agua
dentro de lo ya poco
en el río la presencia de los gendarmes
no asusta a la población en cama y
tampoco las fuerzas del orden francesas
en misión contra la extracción ilegal de
oro residen en este pueblo de 1.800
habitantes el cabo ya es marc antoine
vino desde la metrópolis con un contrato
de cuatro años y banca móvil con su
mujer y su bebé que nació en cayenne
tienes que estirar las piernas estira
las piernas
no no no
pero dobla las piernas y las doblas mira
sí pero estos son los pañales nuevos
mira lo elásticos que son pues son
horribles hay que cruzarlo y listo o que
ya no hay fugas
la pareja tuvo que adaptarse a las
condiciones de vida locales incluida la
atención médica brindada en la única
clínica de camping
no tenemos mucho de qué preocuparnos
sólo por la salud de la bebé sí está
bien todo está bien cuando volvimos a
kamov y tenía tres días de nacida y
entonces todo va muy bien si tenemos
alguna duda venimos aquí sabemos que la
clínica siempre está abierto
aquí la porosidad de la frontera también
es evidente 20 por ciento de los
pacientes son brasileños y para ella
podrías añadir una línea ya lo hice
tengo una piragua para el 5 pero ya
llegaría allí hacia el mediodía oa la
una de la tarde no sé hasta qué hora
está abierto el consultorio
benoit quintín es enfermero en la
clínica de camps y desde hace 7 años
bien desde hace un año el médico le está
insistiendo que se haga una operación
para extraer el útero y así podría dejar
de tener sangrados
en el pueblo brasileño de esta paciente
justo enfrente de camps y solo hay una
enfermera para 600 habitantes no es
suficiente para atender todas las
urgencias
y
aquí ya me hicieron un tratamiento al
otro lado y fue muy lento entonces
busqué un médico en brasil el
tratamiento no era mejor la situación
empeoró
yo estaba cada vez más mal ahora de que
el tratamiento más adecuado está aquí
del lado francés
hasta luego hasta luego vaya con dios
a pesar del cierre oficial de la
frontera para luchar contra la pandemia
la clínica sigue funcionando a plena
capacidad
el kamov y el cabo sanz marc antoine y
sus colegas se han acostumbrado al
constante ir y venir de las piraguas
las personas que cruzan la frontera no
buscan instalarse en francia para
obtener documentos en absoluto solo
quieren trabajar porque es algo que
siempre se ha hecho obligamos que hace
parte de las tradiciones nosotros les
explicamos que la frontera está cerrada
pero no vamos a detener a las personas
por haberla cruzado a lo largo del río
yaqui las poblaciones locales juegan al
gato y al ratón con las fuerzas del
orden en saint george's orly y su madre
van a hacer las compras en el lado
brasileño el barquero que los llevará
hasta el otro lado no parece preocupado
por el carácter ilegal de su actividad
por lo general patrullan por el río a
partir de las 2 de la tarde hasta las 5
la policía de fronteras de controles por
la mañana entre las 10 y las 12 y por la
tarde suelen ser los gendarmes a esta
hora está tranquilo
diez minutos y ocho euros es todo lo que
se necesita para pasar de francia a
brasil el precio del cruce se duplicó
desde que la frontera está oficialmente
cerrada
pero el 40 por ciento de las familias de
san george son brasileñas
al igual que orly todas cruzan a menudo
el río para visitar a sus familiares o
hacer compras
aquí este producto cuesta 259 reales
pero en saint george un producto si
cuesta dos o tres euros
no podemos comprar todo esto en seniors
en 50 euros
gracias bueno es lo que estaba diciendo
puesto 240 reales son unos 25 o 30 euros
entre la guayana francesa y brasil eloy
a poch y sigue siendo una zona de
intercambio más que una línea divisoria
y la pandemia de kobe que supuestamente
cerró la frontera de manera hermética no
hizo más que evidenciar su carácter
incontrolable
[Música]
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerda que para visualizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]